[Music]
this is the chick-fil-a chicken sandwich
which according to multiple industry
surveys is america's favorite fast food
visit a chick-fil-a anywhere in the
united states and you're likely to see a
long line of customers patiently waiting
to order the restaurant's flagship menu
items there you guys go thank you so
much pleasure y'all have a great rest of
you in part thanks to its famous chicken
today chick-fil-a is the third largest
u.s restaurant chained by domestic sales
we're still seeing tremendous growth in
our business so far this year we're up
about 20 percent so
how did this private atlanta-based fast
food chain become one of the most
popular restaurants in america
this is the economics of chick-fil-a
chick-fil-a has long had a unique
approach to business that the company
credits with its success
from the beginning chick-fil-a's
business was built on a recipe after
testing hundreds of methods
restauranteur truett kathy developed a
faster way to cook boneless chicken
using a pressure cooker and peanut oil
it's perfect and so we've kept that
locked away in a vault and we'll
continue to use that same recipe none of
the employees have access to it so it is
still shrouded in a lot of mystery there
are recipe sites where you can try to
recreate it but they have never put it
out officially the original chicken
sandwich is the same today as in 1967 a
breaded breast of chicken two pickles
both placed on a buttered toasted bun
[Music]
chick-fil-a has long taken pride for its
commitment to selling a high quality
product
in fact chick-fil-a's name is a take on
chicken filet with a capital a at the
end symbolizing top quality
while other fast food chains tend to
expand their menu offerings over time to
attract new customers chick-fil-a's
business model has always been to
maintain a small menu focused on chicken
sandwiches they like to say it's simple
so
they want to keep
customers knowing what's on that menu to
be able to easily decipher what they
want we think about the way that we
serve guests that consistency is really
important that we get hot sandwiches
cold salads and just tasty products
customers seem to agree since its
creation in 2015 the american customer
satisfaction index has been dominated by
chick-fil-a chick-fil-a often rates very
high even though the service and the
drive-through can be slower people are
very happy with the quality of the
service they get in general
today many chick-fil-a restaurants use a
practice known as upstream ordering
where an associate will take a
customer's order while they're still
waiting in line this started before the
pandemic but has really proved very
important to the pandemic when they
closed their dining rooms which
really meant the drive-through is the
major channel of sales so if you go to a
chick-fil-a now in many locations you
will see workers out in the
drive-through with tablets and so
instead of speaking into a speaker box
and kind of mumbling your order and
maybe getting screwed up you're telling
this person directly next your car what
you want to ensure that quality in every
one of its locations chick-fil-a uses a
different franchise model than most
other fast food chains
unlike most chains where the franchisee
covers most of the costs of opening the
restaurant chick-fil-a owns every one of
its locations the company also selects
the locations and builds the restaurants
we really think that that's a key
differentiator in the way that we
operate we're not looking for a
financial investor or people that want
to buy big market and open a bunch of
stores chick-fil-a states on their
website franchising is not an
opportunity for passive financial
investment working from the sidelines or
adding to a portfolio of business
ventures franchisees are called
operators and each operator is
hand-picked by chick-fil-a after a
rigorous interview process
chick-fil-a likes to say it's about like
going to
harvard mba it can take anywhere from 12
months to 24 months so you really have
to want to do this and be willing to go
through the initial paperwork but then
extensive interviews out of the more
than 8 000 applicants chick-fil-a
receives annually the company only
selects about 130 new operators a year
that's an acceptance rate lower than
stanford
one of the skills that we really look
for is somebody that's really good at
developing people a lot of the stores
having over 100 employees they've got to
be really really good at pouring in and
developing people and teams and
leadership teams if selected chick-fil-a
franchisees need only an initial
investment of ten thousand dollars which
covers the franchise fee to become an
operator that's much lower than the
startup cost for a mcdonald's franchise
which requires a 45 000 franchise fee as
well as 1.3 to 2.3 million dollars of
additional investment if they're at 10
or 15 locations it's hard to have that
market presence and to really know their
team members and the communities that we
serve and we've got a lot of interest to
become operators and feel like that
model is going to be really important
it's what's gotten us to where we are
chick-fil-a credits this hands-on
approach with the success of its
restaurants which on average make far
more off of each location than their
competition
for years chick-fil-a's footprint was
mostly in the southeast but today they
can be found across the country they
have about 2 600 restaurants throughout
the country they're also located in
canada and they are opening in puerto
rico we're opening about 100 stores a
year right now and we've got a lot of
growth potential here just domestically
in the united states but we're also
looking international as well since 2007
chick-fil-a's nearly doubled its
restaurant count to 2598.
compared to a lot of other chains that's
still slow like a chipotle is opening
200 restaurants a year no matter which
chick-fil-a location you eat at the
company says its values are reflected in
its day-to-day operations
it is a very close culture they are also
invested in its values which they do say
are based on judeo-christian values
which you don't have to be a christian
to work there but they do
you know take some of these basic
values of humility and generosity and
if you want to go to a prayer service
while you're there you certainly can
from its inception founder truett
cathy's christian faith played a major
role in the company's business strategy
it's why chick-fil-as are never open on
sunday not just so workers can attend
church but also so they can rest in
general we feel like we make up for the
sales in the monday through saturday and
that anticipation of i can't get
chick-fil-a today so i want to make sure
to go first thing monday morning
it's also the reason the company has
never gone public i don't think we will
ever actually i know we'll never go
public and there's not a real benefit
for us to do that we've grown
conservatively and so we don't need a
lot of investors or extra cash to go and
to build new stores or new businesses
part of kathy's values are reflected in
how employees are treated and how
they're expected to treat customers
thank you my pleasure you'll have a
great day although you won't see it in
restaurants where the employees are
massed up chick-fil-a has long asked
employees to greet customers warmly with
a smile even if it's just a very small
interaction you can share a lot by just
the smile the team member has with
guests it's just a small little thing
that we can do that makes a difference
occasionally chick-fil-a's values have
attracted scrutiny especially when the
company's foundation donates to
conservative groups or causes there's
been some groups perceived as anti-gay
and this is a you know attracted
attention from
progressive groups the company's
foundation in the last year has focused
its terrible giving on three different
areas homelessness
hunger and education
i think the most important thing for us
being in the restaurant business is that
we serve everybody my grandfather i love
how he talked about it with politics he
would say i'm not right wing or
left-wing i'm the whole chicken when you
go to headquarters in atlanta there is
this
rock with a quote from truitt that is
displayed prominently that says what
chick-fil-a's corporate purpose it says
to glorify god by being a faithful
steward of all that is entrusted to us
to have a positive influence on all who
come in contact with chick-fil-a
i do think that
reflects this very higher noble sense of
company self they have they believe they
do more than just serve chicken
sandwiches thank you my pleasure have a
nice one
[Music]